one franchisee has been the butt of
rigor mortis oaks time and time again
has been marvel from Hulk references to
Avengers jokes he is all the times Rick
and Morty poked fun at Marvel in the
season 2 episode total wreck or a Smith
family finds themselves plagued by an
interstellar parasite that has the
ability to implant false memories into
its hosts each time they have a
flashback a new parasite joins their
myths in the form of a wacky character
wait don't leave without letting
photography Raptor take a picture in one
such dubious memory the family along
with their friend mr. poopy bottle is
seen leaving a musical play based on the
life of the Hulk they seemed pretty
excited about the play and Jerry is even
wearing a pair of fake Hulk hands this
is actually a two-for-one reference that
not only gives a nod to the big green
guy but also seems to be an allusion to
the real disastrous spider-man Broadway
musical that injured several stunt
performers starting back in 2010 a
number of these injuries were
life-threatening and the play
experienced a range of other calamities
with a price tag of 75 million dollars
spider-man turn off the dark is a most
expensive broadway musical ever made and
even though it holds the broadway box
office record for single week sales
taking in 2.9 million dollars over a
span of nine performances it still lost
nearly 16 million dollars in a show with
as rabid a fanbase as ricky matee it's
hard to pick any single episode as a fan
favorite but two that stand out are the
interdimensional cable anthologies in
the second installments we've briefly
introduced to octopus man as he somewhat
nonsensically gets into a car with a
mysterious driver bearing a scar across
his face claiming to be a marine
biologist who was bitten by an octopus
which thereby turned him into a half
human half octopus octopus man is
obviously a riff on spider-man but while
Spidey is a good guy octopus man claims
to save people which basically
translates to him stabbing random people
on the street so maybe he's really more
akin to Spider Man's nemesis a dr.
octopus or maybe in an episode is overly
nutty as this particular one it's best
not to dig too deep for logic well
summer maybe people that create things
are concerned with your delicate
sensibilities
you know when Rick and Morty find
themselves on the purge planet in season
two's Lucas
now a moment comes when it seems like
they're cornered once and for all then
Rick's earlier message to summer pays
off and suddenly Rick and Morty are
decked out in a pair of battle suits
that seems suspiciously similar to those
worn by Iron Man and war machine not
only do these suits compact with a
seemingly endless series of gadgets used
for attacking an adversary in every way
imaginable and not only are their
wearers practically invincible but even
the delivery method is strikingly
similar to something Tony Stark would
have designed the real kicker is a song
that plays on a su surface activated
feels good by the RMV group Tony Tony
Tony if that's not a sneaky Tony Stark
reference we don't know what is in the
show's third season we're introduced to
the Vindicator x' a team of oddball
superheroes that are about as obvious
and knockoff of the Avengers as it gets
[Music]
refused to answer a literal call to
adventure Morty let it go to voicemail
first of all there's the name as
vindicate and avenge are basically
synonymous then there are the two group
symbols because when you turn the
Vindicator symbol upside down it looks
suspiciously similar to that of the
Avengers the story of The Vindicator x'
is in itself extremely Avenger e we meet
the team in Vindicator 3 the return of
world ender in which has made clear that
there was a first Vindicator team that
included Rick and Morty as well as a
second one they skipped for reasons that
remain vague this article says the
reason we weren't involved was
personality conflicts could this be a
reference to the second Avengers film
age of Ultron which many agree was one
of the lesser MCU installments at one
point Rick also explicitly refers to
Morty's Vindicator space and as we all
know the MCU releases are broken up into
a series of phases that's the episode of
indicators 3 the return of world ender
makes blatantly clear said superhero
group has assembled to do battle against
a being called world ender little is
known about the villain other than the
fact that he possesses create power and
a taste for genocide vindicate earth
where
ender is back and this time he's out to
end more than world's sound like anyone
familiar this is almost certainly a
teasing ripoff of Thanos or Galactus or
maybe even both
he's a cliche mega villain who's
supposedly insufferable unless facing
the combined might of the of indicators
his on-the-nose name also seems to point
out how tired audiences are becoming of
these over-the-top bodies if world Endor
is supposed to be some kind of Sano
style enemy who verges on
invulnerability Rick and Morty sticks
his tongue girl to this concept once
again while revealing that rick has
effortlessly defeated him off screen or
blackout drunk no offense but I've
always suspected that a lot of what you
do in a year could be knocked out in a
couple of hours among the most popular
of the MCU leading characters is
star-lord leader of the guardians of the
galaxy played by one of the most beloved
superstars in Hollywood star-lord is
known face charm good looks humor and
bravery his courage has been
instrumental in saving the galaxy on
multiple occasions even if his lack of
self-control did directly result in the
Thanos snap which erase half of all the
life in the universe but that's a
different conversation in any case
star-lord got the Rick and Morty
treatment and vindicated 3 the return of
world ender with the appearance of
indicators member Vance Maximus renegade
star soldier voiced by the hilarious
Christian Slater like star-lord he flies
around with a jetpack wields some kind
of Raygun and seems to offer plenty of
swagger and wit sorry I'm late
it was happy hour however unlike
star-lord who spends much of his screen
time acting in his own self-interests
before coming through as a hero in the
end
Maximus does the opposite selfishly
attempting to save his own skin before
getting brutally slain for his efforts
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos but
your favorite shows are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and at
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]